tengo una pregunta para ti
recuerdas que soñaba ser cuando eras
joven
probablemente soñabas
un músico o un bombero un maestro
un científico un doctor
tal vez un artista probablemente un
pintor
un arquitecto
o tal vez un deportista profesional
que soñaba ser cuando eras joven
imagínate que frente a ti oa un lado
tuvieras una máquina del tiempo y que
pudieras meterte en esta máquina del
tiempo así bueno porque es chiquita y
pudiera transportar pequeños
y regresar a cuando eras joven y cuando
tenías este sueño
todos hemos estado ahí
probablemente lo que hacías cuando eras
joven es que te ponías a interpretar
como si fueras un artista un cantante
frente al espejo y estabas ahí cantando
o probablemente lo que hacías es que
salías al jardín y recolectamos plantas
y recolectaba piedritas animales y
después regresaban
a tu cuarto como si fuera tu laboratorio
o probablemente lo que hacías es que
ponías frente a ti a tus muñecos o tus
muñecas y les estaba dando una clase
como si fueras su maestro
o tal vez lo que te gustaba era hablar y
decir los diálogos de una película como
en eitb que el particular soy un fan de
rocky o probablemente lo que hacías es
que te ponías frente a la televisión y
le hacías de reportero soy catalanista
estoy aquí en vivo y en directo
transmitiendo
todos estuvimos ahí
pero sobre todo quiero que te imagines y
que sientas esa emoción que tenías de la
posibilidad de que sabías que este sueño
que estabas teniendo también podía ser
real
yo estuve allí
igual que tú estuve y tenía un sueño de
ser un futbolista profesional yo quería
ser un futbolista profesional y este era
mi sueño y todos los días me levantaba
con este sueño mi sueño era jugar para
los mejores equipos de inglaterra pero
también jugar para la selección de
méxico y jugar en los campeonatos del
mundo jugar los mejores torneos y
representar a méxico ese era mi sueño y
todos los días salía para poder lograr
este sueño
y este sueño era tan real que cada vez
que yo salía sentía que realmente en
lugar de estar en el parque yo no estaba
en el parque yo estaba jugando en los
mejores estadios en los estadios que
estaban llenos de gente y los podía
escuchar
yo no jugaba con mis amigos o con mi
amigo beto con mi hermano juan o mi
primo jorge yo jugaba con los más
picudos yo jugaba con zidane con beckham
con roberto carlos con romario con los
mejores y yo no le metía goles a
porterías que estaban pintadas en la
pared con hits o con ladrillo o
probablemente porterías que estaban
marcadas con dos piedras que teníamos
que quitar cuando pasaban los coches yo
le metía goles a porterías que medían
dos metros y que estaban cubiertas por
porteros que si levantaban los brazos
cubrían toda la portería y era una
pasión increíble aunque si hubieras
estado ahí y hubieras dado cuenta que
los porteros bueno media no menos de 150
saltaban menos de una tortilla y la
mejor forma de meterles un gol era de
tirarles por arriba
y esto era tan real que cada vez que
alguno de nosotros teníamos el balón
yo podía escuchar el estadio
y también podía escuchar a los
comentaristas que estaban narrando la
pelota la lleva ramón se quita uno se
quita otro se la da marcelino marcelino
se la da galván galván se quita uno
galván disparado
con de galván y yo salía corriendo y
abrazaba a mis compañeros y estaba muy
muy contento y estará una alegría enorme
y de repente abría los ojos y me daba
cuenta que estaba abrazando a los
árboles y a las bugambilias que estaban
en el jardín o en el parque y era una
experiencia increíble
pero me di cuenta de algo que yo quería
mandar un mensaje porque cada vez que
metía un gol yo me levantaba la camiseta
y debajo de esta camiseta tenía otra que
tenía un mensaje
y el mensaje era
no espera un poco pero lo que buscaba
hacer es realmente poder conectar con
otros y decirles si yo tengo un sueño y
lo estoy logrando tú también lo puedes
hacer y cada vez que alguien lo
entrevistaba yo buscaba dar este mensaje
o un mensaje positivo y sobre todo a
méjico diciéndoles que éramos y somos
unos chingones
y esto era lo que yo quería hacer una
entrevista mención galván que opina
sobre el partido y yo sea un partido
difícil como todos dicen pero después
buscaba meter una frase algo como hemos
llegado lejos gracias a que trabajamos
en equipo y como dice el proverbio
africano si quieres llegar rápido ve
solo pero si quieres llegar lejos ve
acompañado y esto es lo que yo estaba
buscando hacer constantemente y era un
sueño y un momento fantástico
pero de repente
este sueño se empezó a nublar
y ya no se veía igual
la vela la luz se empezó a pagar
las voces de galván lleva la pelota se
fueron cambiando por
y ahora qué
qué hago con mi vida esto no está
saliendo como yo esperaba qué hago
y de repente me di cuenta que yo no era
el único que le estaba pasando lo mismo
a mis amigos mis compañeros a mis
conocidos que me habían contado de sus
sueños de sus grandes sueños que veía
que tampoco los habían logrado les
preguntaba ya qué pasó por qué no
lograste tu sueño qué fue lo que sucedió
y me decían no lo que pasa es que mis
jefes me dijeron que estudiara esto no
obligaron a estudiar esto y después
encontré un trabajo y pues paga bien y
mejor aquí ya me quedo cómodo
otros me decían o lo que pasa es que en
méxico eso no se puede en otros países
si se puede hacer pero en méxico eso no
se puede
otros me decían o lo que pasa es que
conocí a esta persona empezamos a salir
nos embaraza vamos y pues ya hay que
sentar cabeza y ya mejor acá
otros me decían muy típico o lo que pasa
es que me lastimé la rodilla
pero si no me lo había lastimado te juro
que estaría jugando en el real madrid
y bueno y yo me empecé a hacer la
pregunta
porque porque yo no lo logré
por qué
no lo logras te tú qué pasó yo me di
cuenta que al principio también le
estaba echando la culpa a todos es que
esto es por el otro
pero hubo un momento en donde me di
cuenta que lo que estaba haciendo es que
no me estaba siendo responsable de mi
vida y no estaba haciendo el capitán de
mi propio destino lo que me daba miedo
era fracasar me da miedo salirme de mi
zona de confort me daba miedo tener esas
experiencias y entonces dije mejor aquí
me quedo donde estoy cómodo
pero no quería salir y que otros me
dijeran no es que no eres lo
suficientemente bueno
y entonces me quedé ahí pero también lo
que pasa es que estaba escuchando a
otras personas otras voces que me decían
no no no es lo que tú quieres
eso de ser futbolista profesional para
los que no estudian no no no va a ser
realista eso es un sueño es una tontería
ya mejor sienta cabeza
y poco a poco también estoy escuchando
y un momento
desperté
y me di cuenta que el sueño se había
terminado
yo estaba en inglaterra y estaba
buscando jugar con equipos profesionales
estaba mandando las cartas todas se
mandaban cartas en aquello entonces
pidiéndoles una oportunidad y todos me
contestaban y decían gracias pero no
gracias estás muy viejo y el tren
y la sensación que tuve en ese momento
es una sensación terrible y allí entendí
una frase muy buena de benjamin franklin
que dice la mayoría de la gente muere a
los 25 años y le entierran a los 75 años
yo tenía 25 años y por dentro estaba
muerto estaba podrido me sentía mal lo
que hago con mi vida todo este sueño que
había construido ya nunca será la
sensación era terrible
y de repente
algo cambio
me corrieron de mi trabajo
estaba yo en el trabajo yo había
estudiado sistemas y me estaba en un
trabajo en el cual me pagaban por hora
nalga es decir por estar sentado horas y
hora oreja por hacer llamadas y de
repente me habló mi jefa no mi mamá sino
mi jefa de trabajo y mi hijo pepe
buscáis muy bien eres muy buena persona
pero la verdad es que lo que hasta aquí
no es muy bueno pero veo que tienes
otras habilidades y que vale la pena que
las maximicen y que hagas lo más que
puedas con esto
y desde ese momento dije nunca más nunca
más voy a estar trabajando o
desperdiciando mi tiempo en algo que no
me ayude a construir este sueño ya que
yo realmente pueda lograr mi potencial
como ser humano la razón y propósito por
el cual estoy aquí
y 10 años después
estoy aquí increíble no lo puedo creer
increíble estoy contándote un poco de
cómo le di la vuelta a mi carrera y a mi
vida y como tú le puedes dar una segunda
oportunidad a tu sueño
probablemente te estés preguntando qué
hiciste bueno lo que hice fue
desarrollar un concepto llamado six pack
mental easy experimental es muy similar
así como cuando vas al gimnasio y vas a
entrenar al cuerpo los músculos bueno no
todos aquí por algunos de ustedes y vas
a realmente sacarle el potencial al
músculo lo que tiene adentro lo mismo
con shakespeare mental sacar el
potencial del ser humano y lo que tiene
para poder realmente maximizar lo que
tiene el ser humano lo que ha sido
fascinante es que en los últimos años
junto a mi equipo que les agradezco
mucho también porque ellos me han
ayudado muchísimo es que he podido
trabajar con jugadores con equipos con
organizaciones y federaciones con las
cuales yo quería jugar y este sueño se
ha vuelto realidad ha sido completamente
como no lo esperaba pero ha sido
increíble porque he podido ayudar a
jugadores que han jugado para la
selección de méxico que han jugado
mundiales que han jugado para otras
selecciones entrenadores que han ganado
campeonatos del mundo
en inglaterra champions league en los
mejores niveles jugadores jóvenes que
tienen el mismo sueño que yo tenía pero
no sólo eso sino también empresas
emprendedores amas de casa doctores
porque todos al final tenemos un
potencial pero para poder desarrollarlo
hay que entrenarlo constantemente
y si te digo esto no es para presumir
sino simplemente para compartir contigo
como tú puedes hacer lo mismo si tienes
un sueño que quieres cumplir y darle una
segunda oportunidad lo que quiero hacer
es compartir contigo tres puntos que
considero que han sido esenciales en mi
carrera profesional y también con
aquellos que he podido trabajar
y el primer punto que quiero compartir
contigo es un propósito y muchas
misiones un propósito en muchas misiones
porque considero que esto es importante
es importante que tú consideres tú para
qué para qué estás aquí mark twain tiene
una muy buena frase que dice los dos
días más importantes en tu vida son el
día que naces el día que descubres para
qué naciste
sin importar la edad que tengas joven
viejo considero que es importante que
descubras para que estás aquí y que
probablemente tu primera misión que
lanzas no llega como la mía el fútbol
lance esta misión
no llegó y hubo un momento dije no puede
ser que hago pero me di cuenta que hay
otras misiones que puedo lanzar a través
de otros vehículos y tú puedes hacer lo
mismo hay otras formas de poder lograr
este propósito que tienes en la vida
porque es esto
porque estás vivo porque hoy tienes una
oportunidad
quiero compartir te el segundo punto
qué es la fórmula perfecta para un sueño
frustrado y esta fórmula dice así dices
menos acción igual a frustración dices
qué sabes esto dice es que conoces esto
dices que vas a hacer esto dices dices
dices y no haces
un sueño frustrado esta es la fórmula
perfecta así que te invito a que
empieces a tomar acción en tu vida y que
no solamente lo pienses porque dice
significa datos información
conocimientos experiencias y sabiduría
vivimos en una época en donde tenemos
acceso a demasiada información pero lo
que nos falta es tomar acción
y entonces dices bueno cómo le hago para
tomar acción y aquí está el tercer punto
la mayoría de la gente no toma acción en
mi punto de vista por dos razones número
uno porque se abruma el sueño dice es
que está muy grande no sé cómo lo voy a
hacer mejor no empieza número 2 dice si
voy a empezar voy a hacer todo lo que
pasa en año nuevo y le voy a meter con
todo pero es como querer ir al gimnasio
y cargar 100 kilos sin nunca haber ido
al gimnasio y entonces después de dos o
tres dices díaz dices no está muy
difícil y te das por vencido
y aquí es en donde quiero presentarte lo
que a mí me ha ayudado mucho y espero
que te ayude a ti también 1%
1 % tú y yo hoy partimos de un punto y
en seis meses existen tres versiones de
ti en el futuro
el primero es tu superior uno que está
constantemente avanzando que estás
evolucionando el segundo es un yo x ni
picha ni cacha y dejas batear te casas
y el tercero es tu mínimo sumersión tu
versión así chiquita te va siendo más
chiquita
y todo va a depender de las decisiones
que tomes y las acciones que tomes pero
te invito a que tomes acciones de 1%
poco a poco que vayas avanzando como
esta bola de nieve que va creciendo va
creciendo y de repente una avalancha y
es que mucha gente dice no es que 1% una
cosa es una palabra nueva
no es nada no es nada
13 1 % es la diferencia muchas veces
entre la vida y la muerte ese 1% es la
diferencia entre si escogen tu proyecto
o el de alguien más ese 1% es la
diferencia entre si entre el balón pega
en el poste
ese 1% fue la diferencia que hizo que tú
estuvieras aquí hoy vivo y no alguien
más
1 por ciento 1 por ciento y que vayas
avanzando poco a poco y que al final de
tu día te puede ser una pregunta soy
mejor ahora que cuando desperté sí o no
si constantemente estás contestando sí
sí sí quiere decir que estás avanzando
quiere decir que estás progresando y
vale la pena festejar este progreso y al
final te darás cuenta que no es el sueño
y que llegues si no está en el camino en
cada acción en el proceso es donde se
disfruta donde realmente lo puedes vivir
y dónde lo puedes también festejar
y qué mejor forma de festejar cómo se
festeja un gol
y te tengo un reto hoy
te invito a que hoy en este momento
festejes conmigo como si hubieras metido
un gol esta posibilidad que tienes de
darle una segunda oportunidad a tu sueño
que tú y yo podamos festejar que estamos
vivos que estamos acá que tenemos esta
oportunidad increíble y lo festejamos
como se festeja
un golf
les parece
pero como se festeja un gol se festeja a
sentados o parados entonces porque nos
paramos porque la jugada está muy
cercana y lo vamos a festejar no yo lo
voy a narrar y acompáñenme a festejar
este gol pero quiero que pienses que
estás festejando su gol tu oportunidad
que tienes de estar vivo y darle una
segunda oportunidad a tu sueño y rompas
este muro mental listo
lleva la pelota ramón se quita uno la
gente se emociona empieza a gritar no
está alentando batir a alberto garcía
después la toca delante quita uno se
quita otro se lo agarra dispara
[Música]
el mundo mágico
si yo puedo
tú también puedes gracias
[Aplausos]
no
[Música]